[Musique]
la fuite massive de données personnelles
touchant 3 millions de membres de
desjardins le 20 juin dernier a provoqué
une véritable onde de choc la nouvelle
technologie financière de l'open banking
prendre l'ampleur on en parle souvent et
on se demande aujourd'hui si nos données
bancaires serait mieux au moins bien
protégée avec le système bancaire ouvert
avec nous ils gabriel leboeuf
cofondateur de flex
bonsoir qui offre quoi des services au
secteur financier pour développer
notamment le système bancaire ouvert si
je dis que le système bancaire ouvert
c'est de sortir un peu nos données de la
possession des banques puis d'en prendre
le contrôle
est ce que c'est une bonne définition
parce que c'est une bonne définition en
ce sens dans le sens où c'est un peu de
donner le contrôle aux consommateurs de
faire ce qu'ils veulent avec la donnée
financière et leur argent
c'est quelque chose qu'on voit
aujourd'hui en europe c'est quelque
chose qu'on entend de plus en plus au
canada
c'est quelque chose que nous à notre
entreprise flint faisons des jeux de
point de vue technologique
ouais parce que en ce moment on ne peut
pas faire ce qu'on veut avec nos données
bancaires en fait c'est à la merci des
décisions financières donc en ce moment
si on regarde au canada certaines
questions financières kiwi offre
facilement d'accéder aux données
financières mais on a d'autres par
contre qu'ils considèrent que ça ces
données financières devraient leur
appartenir que c'est excessivement
difficile donc pour une entreprise comme
la nôtre d'aller chercher ses données
financières le ce qui crée un peu des
barrières en termes de compétition pour
nous les consommateurs canadiens
quand on pense par exemple aller
chercher un prêt hypothécaire ou tout
simplement à transcrire nous active dans
une autre question financière qu'est ce
que voulait dire par derrière dans le
sens russie par exemple tous vos actifs
étaient dans une incision financière
qu'on veut nommer les sillons financière
bleus puisque vous vouliez changer vers
une autre récession financière gestion
financière rouge dans cet exemple si ça
pourrait potentiellement être très
difficile de considérer vos actifs par
exemple puisque josé part du succès que
ça pourrait demander plusieurs coups de
téléphone plusieurs courriels à vos
nouveaux conseillers vos anciens
conseillers au bout de la ligne
finalement être un processus qui prend
énormément de temps et donc si le
système bancaire était ouvert on
pourrait faire si facilement exacte non
dans le fond ça peut sonner un peu
bizarre
tendre ouvert puis bancaire dans la même
phrase mais a priori c'est de donner le
pouvoir vraiment aux consommateurs de
pouvoir dire dans le fond bien ça c'est
mes données
c'est mon argent je veux maintenant la
transférer dans cette institution
financière ce qui pourrait se faire de
façon pratiquement instantanée avec la
technologie qu'on a développé les
banques en ce moment et des jardins des
incisions financière ne fonctionnent pas
dans un système bancaire ouvert c'est
exact d'enfants au canada on n'a pas de
système bancaire ouvert donc
l'alternative c'est dans le fond de
construire des connexions qui permet de
faire vraiment une petite portion de ce
qu'on voit dans d'autres pays comme par
exemple en europe en grande bretagne ou
même à singapour ou en australie mais
vraiment kahn a donné on est
présentement si loin de ceux
malheureusement si desjardins avait
fonctionné selon le système bancaire
ouvert le système ouvert
est ce qu'on aurait pu éviter le vol de
données de trois millions d'entre eux
l'ex en question mais je pense pas que
ça aurait pu éviter le vol de données
par contre ce que ça pourrait faire
c'est que ça pourrait sécuriser les
membres qui aujourd'hui ont eu une
identité qui pourrait qu'on pourrait
considérer compromise en allant par
exemple protéger l'accès à leur dossier
de crédit par l'entremise c'est un
manque à voir donc si par exemple vos
données avaient été compromises
ce que le pen ben king pourrait faire
c'est d'aller carrément bloqué votre
dossier de crédit puis vous obligez vous
comme consommateur allait consentir à
l'accès au dossier crédit avec quelqu'un
puisse par exemple aller prendre une
carte de crédit en votre nom
et c'est quoi la différence avec ce
qu'on a vécu est ce qu'on vit
présentement la solution qui est protégé
avec l'information que j'ai aujourd'hui
c'est une sélection qu'on pourrait
considérer comme étant réactif dans le
sens où encore une fois si quelqu'un
faisait une demande de carte de crédit
en votre nom
vous pourriez être alertés qu'une
demande de carte de crédit en votre nom
par contre une solution qui pourrait
potentiellement arriver un peu trop tard
dans le sens où la carte de crédit
pourraient déjà avoir été émises aux
pirates informatiques qui a fait cette
demande si vous me décrivez le système
de kiki fax par exemple c'est ça en
compte
ok on alors qu'avec un système bancaire
ouvert ce qu'on pourrait venir faire
c'est créer dans le fond pour que gérald
obtienne sa carte de crédit
gerald devrait se connecter à son compte
de banque pour consentir à l'accès à ce
nouveau produit de crédits le ski est
quelque chose qu'on voit dans d'autres
pays encore une fois c'est pas un
concept qui est complètement nouveau ici
au canada mais c'est quelque chose qu'on
entend de plus en plus parler même au
niveau du ministère des finances
je me rends fédéral qui regardent de
plus en plus à comment est-ce qu'on
pourrait établir c'est ici au canada
mais qui fasse mes propos sauf s'il se
passe des choses sur mon compte on va
m'appeler on compte
acte de façon réactive et non proactive
ce que je veux dire par proactive encore
une fois c'est que vous pourriez
carrément dans un système encore verts
allaient bloquer l'accès à votre dossier
de crédit par l'entremise de votre
gestion financière ce qu'on ne peut pas
faire de mal heureusement non le blocage
que nous un gouvernement de le
gouvernement legault étudie la
possibilité d'adopter de déposer un
projet de loi d'adopter une nouvelle loi
l'exode donc ça viendrait est ce que ce
serait le système bancaire ouvert où se
seraient simplement sur le bloquer on
pourrait interpréter se commettant une
petite partie d'un système manque à
l'ouvreur par contre ce que ces projets
ce que cette loi le de ma compréhension
du projet qui est qui est suggéré vient
faire c'est vraiment plus haut niveau
seulement du dossier de crédit donc je
parlais tantôt par exemple du transfert
d'actifs du transfert de passif qui
transporte carrément de tous vos comptes
de banque d'une institution financière à
l'autre c'est pas quelque chose qui
proposait présent le management vous
vous travaillez que la banque nationale
parmi les clients parmi les clients
reconnaissent que c'est la seule banque
avec qui vous travaillez avec plusieurs
actions financières au canada à
plusieurs égards on a une très grande
popularité dans les plus petites
questions financières
parce que en fait ce que fait notre
technologie permet aussi d'augmenter la
compétitivité sur les marchés
notre désir c'est de faire des livres de
la rectorie nation parce que je
regardais aujourd'hui on sent un peu de
résistance quand même dans le milieu
financier je voyais guy cormier par
exemple pdg de desjardins dit oui à des
avantages mais on n'est pas assez
outillés pour qu'on ouvre aujourd'hui
les données il ya des gens qui
pourraient pas très bien profiter de ce
système là parce qu'ils sont pas très
bons nécessairement technologies les cp
au disque est un enjeu de
confidentialité la banque du canada
s'inquiète de la stabilité financière
il ya encore des choses à faire pour que
tout le monde adhère
je pense que oui mais en même temps si
on regarde ce qui se fait à
l'international des régions dans le
monde qui ont des années d' avance sur
ce qu'on vit présentement canada c'est
des questions qui se sont déjà posés
ailleurs dans le monde
je pense qu'on a beaucoup à apprendre à
regarder ce qui se fait ailleurs dans le
monde
je pense que c'est peut-être des
craintes qui viennent toucher les plus
grandes institutions financières parce
que quand même un enjeu ou des crânes
vraiment de leur côté sur la
compétitivité des produits
est ce qu'une banque par exemple comme
les fameuses challenge bien qu'il
offrait vraiment des comptes de banque à
zéro frais
ce qu'ils vont réellement venir voler
nos profits six à neuf grandes décisions
financières possiblement je pense que
c'est la compétition qui est sienne par
contre je pense qu'il faut vraiment se
passer de l'équipe à l'international il
gabriel leboeuf
merci très intéressant les influences du
coup